JEFF KEMBER: Hello, hey,
thanks for coming today, guys.
Appreciate everyone being here
this early in the morning.
If I could get everybody just
to kind of move on up, please.
So we can get the group
a little bit tighter.
That'd be great, please.
And sorry we're a
couple minutes late
getting rolling this morning.
But again, thank you
all for being here.
My name's Jeff Kember.
I am a Cloud Solutions
Architect with the GCP team.
And in a former life, I
was a CG sup at Framestore.
And I've had the
pleasure of working
at companies such as Blizzard
and Island and Pixar.
We're going to have a couple
different speakers come up
and chat with you today.
I wanted to introduce a
new Solutions Architect
that we have.
So I have a media background
from the film industry.
And our latest hire, his
second week with the company,
Adrian Graham in the
red shirt over there.
Please give Adrian
a big welcome.
For those of you
who know Adrian,
he is former Digital Domain
in this very building.
We worked together here, and
he spent the last couple years
at Autodesk working on Bifrost
and other cool next-generation
Maya technology.
So this really is, I think,
an additional statement
on Google's emphasis
to this market
vertical that they're
employing people like us
to do this kind of work.
So really excited
to work with Adrian,
and he's based here
in Venice office.
So Google's Cloud
offering, we have
a variety of custom solutions,
and we also have Zync.
And I'm sure most people
are familiar with it,
but I will go through it
and talk just a little bit
about it.
It's a fantastic Cloud
rendering solution
for those who have
the opportunity
to be able to work with a clean
sheet version of Maya or Nuke.
We have a Cloud rendering
solution for you.
It allows you to
render on demand,
and it enables-- there's
a Cloud file system.
Your files get uploaded.
And licensing is
handled for you.
So any of these products are
available on a per minute
demand basis.
The way the architecture
works is you
have an open source
plug-in that you download,
and it works with Maya
and Nuke currently.
And you're able to
take your scene,
encapsulate it, and put
it up onto the Cloud.
Your files are stored in
a persistent file system.
And the render notes
get spun up for you,
and the pictures come back.
The architecture is such that
once the files are uploaded,
only the change occurs.
With Maya 2016, the
bin files get uploaded
from your local scene.
And all of the render
creation occurs on the Cloud.
So you don't have to do
local writing of ASS files
and such for Arnold,
for instance.
And the same scenario
works with Nuke.
So renders that already
exists in the cloud, when
you want to run a new comp for
all elements that have already
been rendered in
the Cloud, they're
already persistent there.
Your final comp
comes back to you.
So it's a really great
solution for smaller facilities
that don't have custom plug-ins
and their own pipeline.
This gives artists
the opportunity
to scale significantly.
This is what the
interface looks like.
I've already described
how it works.
This is the, basically,
queuing control engine
that lets you see what
the progress of your job
is and see how many render
nodes you're running,
and how they're
progressing in your job.
So here are a number of films
that were created using Zync.
And we're quite happy
with the amount of success
in the marketplace with it.
So we encourage you to try it
if you fit the use case for it.
For medium and large
studios, we have a framework
for creating custom solutions.
And these are the
quick topics I'm
going to run through the day.
It's a lot.
I'll run through it
as quickly as I can.
From an ingest standpoint,
we're peered significantly
with most major
markets on the planet.
We're here in One Wiltshire
and multiple locations
here in Los Angeles.
So your ability to get data into
the Cloud and get it back out
again quickly with
Google's global network,
we've leased ships and
laid fibre under the ocean.
So if you have other facilities
in London or Singapore
or Australia or Canada,
we have the ability
to be able to jump on
and off our network,
but it's private the
entire time it's there.
So normally, connectivity
is going to be over a VPN.
And you're going to either do
that over the public internet
or with a CDI, a Carrier
Direct Interconnect,
or letting up dark fibre.
Either CDI or direct
connect, you get
a 66% reduction in egress fees.
So that is significant.
If you're in a position where
you can light up dark fibre,
we certainly encourage
you to do so.
We have a Google
managed VPN solution
where we manage the threads
and throughput for you.
So it's just plug and
play, and it works.
Initially, we had a conflict
where it didn't work
with Avere, and now it does.
That's been rolled out, so
you can use our product,
or you can roll your own.
Any open source
IPsec VPN will work.
So the fabric that we run
on is really kind of cool.
Google buys roughly 20--
it's like more than 20%
of Intel's global production.
The next closest
Cloud provider buys 1%
of Intel's global production.
A significant portion
of the Intel processors
that we buy go into our
software defined networking.
If you want to know a
little more about it,
released last summer, there's
a paper on Jupiter fabric.
And it's circa 2012.
So it's a snapshot of what the
technology was at that time.
We're obviously a generation
or two newer than that now,
but it's a really cool paper.
And it offers photographs
of our machine racks
in the data center that you
don't normally get to see.
And it also offers
architectural diagrams.
And it's-- Urs is
one of the authors.
It's a cool piece.
There's a blog as
well as a white paper.
So if anyone wants
to nerd out, I
think it's a really great paper.
And it's worth
reading so you have
an understanding of how are
we able to get the throughput
that we do.
The VMs that we have are
running now 16 gig sustained.
So it's not like a
10 GigE connection
with TCP over IP where you're
losing 20% to 30% overhead.
When we say it's a 16 gig
sustained, we really mean that.
The machines have an excess
of 40 gig throughput per box.
So in terms of
Cloud file systems,
some customers are able
to mount NFS directly.
We've announced that we have
Compute opening up in Oregon.
And the cool part
with that is you'll
be just over 20 milliseconds
away from there here in LA.
So West Coast presence,
really excited about that.
That's kind of a late June,
early availability July.
The facility has been up
and running for years,
so it's not a new build.
It's just we're carving
off a chunk of it
and making that available.
Most of our customers end up
putting a Cloud file system.
Even customers in
London where you
can throw a rock to Belgium, and
it's a seven millisecond ping,
you're in a scenario where
bandwidth becomes expensive.
And you're reading all the data
at least twice for motion blur,
as you know.
So in that case, multiple
reads, cash hits in the Cloud
are friendly.
There are a variety
of solutions.
We support managed solutions
such as Gluster from Red Hat.
We also support read
through cache file systems,
Avere, PixCache as well.
The advantage of a read
through cache file system
is the fact that
you can deploy it,
and you have zero
changes to your pipeline,
initially, to get
up and running.
You can make a picture
without modifying anything.
The file system will
immediately look
to see if it's in the cache.
If it's not there, it will go
to the core file or on-prem
and get it for you.
We'll talk a little more
about that architecture.
So this is just a straight-up
Cloud file system.
In this context, you could
deploy our no cost, single mode
filer.
And that is a framework
that we have different file
systems that run underneath it.
But for you, it's a
click to deploy option.
So you get the same
16 gig throughput,
you get a couple
hundred gigs of RAM,
you get terabytes of
local SSD backing you.
And then you can put
between 10 and 64 terabytes
of persistent SSD.
I'll talk more
about the storage,
but it's a pretty
beefy little server.
It's not intended to
be high availability.
It's a single mode.
And it's not fault
tolerant in that regard.
But it works really well
for 50 to 100 nodes.
If you want to
scale beyond that,
Avere is here today to talk
with you about their offering.
The Virtual Ethics T is
a fantastic solution.
What's cool about it
is in this example,
you have the Avere
on-prem, but you also
have a virtual version
of it in the Cloud.
Now, most of you who
have an Avere product
are used to it being a
multi-terabyte box that's
mounted in your data center.
It fronts your core
filer for you on-prem.
The difference with
the cloud version
is that each node has
multiple terabytes on it.
You can have three to start
with, and go to 10, 20, 30.
We've had customers
running 60,000 plus cores
against 18 to 20 Avere
nodes, and the Avere's
not breaking a sweat.
So you can scale up
beyond 50 if you choose.
So that really changes
how you think about it.
The on-prem appliances,
again, a smaller front end
cache where this is
an entire file system.
It's your core
filer in the Cloud.
This is a slightly more
advanced diagram here
which, really, the
point of this is
to try and show you have
on-premises storage as well
as Cloud, and just to show the
cross connects that you have.
This enables you to
run hybrid rendering.
So in this scenario,
you can have
artists submit to their
local workstation,
to the rack over in the corner,
your colo up the street,
and to the Cloud.
You can use a queuing system
that will cut your image up
into a whole bunch
of different tiles,
and you can
distribute it over all
of those different machines.
And that's really exciting.
The local machines
will, of course,
read off the local Avere.
And the Cloud machines
will read off the VFXT.
And Avere's going
to jump on after I'm
up and chat a little
more about their product
and also give you a
demo of the interface.
So from a storage option
standpoint, the primary-- when
you think of Google Cloud
Storage, it's a big blockstore,
and that's not very friendly
for visual effects work.
But it's huge, even exabytes
of data are available on it
currently.
The nice part about
it, though, is
that you can store files
there really inexpensively.
It's 2.6 cents a gig for
the standard Google Cloud
Storage, the GCS offering.
Most visual effects
customers who
are parking data
there, though, will
use the durable
reduced availability.
It's kind of a
strangely named product.
But what it is,
it's $0.02 a gig,
and it enables you to read the
data as frequently as you want.
So for production data, you
want us to run the Cloud,
DRA is a really great solution.
You're not performing
BigQuery and large data
analytic workloads on
it, so you don't need
the super low latency of GCS.
The slightly less availability
but still durable of DRA
is great.
Nearline's a cool product I'll
talk about a little bit later.
It's $0.01 a gig.
It's our competitor to,
basically, LTO tape solutions.
It's two to seven
seconds to retrieve it.
Persistent disk, that
is our word for network
attached storage.
So the standard
is spinning disks.
Most everyone in this industry
is using our distributed SSD
variant of that.
You can do cool things
with it, like take 50 nodes
and mount the PD SSD
read only against them,
and there's your
inexpensive file system.
So it's cool technology.
The last item is local SSD.
And that's the one I really
enjoy working with the most,
just in the fact that it's
super high performance.
For nerds in the
room, right here,
it's 700,000 IOPS
which is really fast.
It's basically the speed
of DDR two speed RAM.
And we currently have it
deployed, four disks, striped,
all that's taken
care of for you.
It's three terabytes in size.
You can go 750
chunks up to three.
And of course,
expect that to go up
in terms of performance
and size over time.
But the cool part
about that is if you're
doing caching operations
or simulation work,
it's really great for IO.
So from a transfer
standpoint, we
have all-- these are just
suggestions for various tools.
You use the gsutil to be able
to communicate with the Cloud
cluster that you've put up.
And then everything from
rsync all the way down to FDT
to commercial offerings
like Aspera and Signiant
are supported.
So asset management, one
of the exciting things--
I don't have a clock, so
I'm just going to check.
There we go.
One of the exciting things about
how to optimize the solution
is looking at your asset
management pipeline.
So who here uses
Shotgun in the room?
Show of hands.
Cool.
Who has their own proprietary
asset management system
that they roll themselves?
OK, great show of hands.
Cool.
So everybody here knows
that if you just throw up
a read through cache file
system, such as the Avere,
and you spin up a whole
bunch of render nodes,
you're still going to have
to transfer everything up.
We've had really good
success with customers
who are doing something
as simple as adding
a single rsync.
So let's say you're
using Alembic.
You cache out the
animator scene.
You do a quick render
of it to make sure
that the bake was good.
And you want to scrub
through and RV and see
that there is--
here's the heavy rig
that you did the
play blast on, here's
the cached version of that.
Scrub back and forth.
The animator goes,
yes, it's good to go.
Punch the button,
and publish it.
At that point, we have people
insert a single rsync line.
That cache file gets
pushed up to the Cloud.
If you over provision
your file system
just a tiny bit on
the Cloud, you're
in a scenario
where there's going
to be very little flushing.
And it's going to
persistent, so by the time
it gets down to lighting,
all you're sending up
is shader values
and light positions,
because you already
have your textures up,
the character's already
up, the cache files are up.
Everything's been
pushed up in advance.
You don't care about
performance with rsync
because it's human time between
when the animator clicks
the button and when production
assigns it to someone
in lighting to pick it up.
The files are already there.
We also encourage people,
just from an optimization
standpoint, to cache, bake
their files in the Cloud.
And again, uploading in
advance is really optimal.
Because our ingress
is free-- I would
agree that there is a cost
to ingress and egress.
But the way it's been
priced is ingress is free,
and egress isn't, for us.
So in that context,
you could push
as much as you want to
the Cloud without having
to pay additional money beyond
using your own balance to do
it.
We have some customers
who do-- what
I thought was clever--
was they have a daughter
process that after
their EXRs are finished,
they'll go through and
create an H.264 of that.
And they'll crush it down
from a bitrate standpoint
of resolution.
And they'll pull just the H.264
down and have a look at it
and make sure that
the characters are
in the right place, the
lighting is correct,
the paint stuck, and all that
like yes, the render is good.
So then they'll actually
download the EXRs
at that point, which
are 4K and 50 AOVs
and the usual thing, half float.
So in that context, you're in
a scenario where you're not
paying egress something
that you're not
sure is a good
render, so to speak.
So from a queuing
standpoint, we have
a variety of queueing partners.
We have representatives
from PipelineFX here today
as well as Thinkbox.
We support Tractor and RUSH.
We have quite a
few customers who
run their own queuing system.
So it's a really hard problem,
as everyone here in the room
knows, and we've been working
with all the providers
of the top queuing
systems to ensure
that their queueing system
works well on our cloud,
it can communicate on-prem
with an existing control head,
back and forth.
So there's varying levels
of cloud integration
with these products but
would happily talk with you
after about more information.
And again, we have reps
from those two companies
here today to talk with you.
So from a licensing
standpoint-- yeah,
when I joined the company about
18 months ago, the group of us
sat down and made a
list of all the things
we needed from a VFX
standpoint, in order
to be able to
deploy in the Cloud.
And like top of the list,
right after Cloud File System,
was Cloud Licensing.
And with permanent
billing, you want
to make sure you can also
render in the same capacity.
It's difficult for me to
get up here and say, hey,
you have 1,200 frame shot.
Let's spin up 1,200 machines.
It's 17 to 24 minutes or two
hours of frame or 2.1 hours,
and you only want to pay for
the 2.1, not round up to three.
The immediate response
I get back on that
is, what about licensing.
So today, Chris Nichols
is here from Chaos Group.
And he can talk
with you a little
after about their Cloud
Licensing solution.
So you can do
permanent licensing
on our Cloud that's
fully dynamic.
Deadline from Thinkbox has
Krakatoa support, as well as
NUKE from the Foundry, pretty
much the whole Foundry product
line, including VRay, as
well, from Chaos Group.
And Qube from Pipeline
FX has currently
beta support for cloud licensing
for their queuing system.
So if you're a Qube user, you'll
be able to scale dynamically
on the cloud as well.
If you're Qube and
VRay, for instance,
you could point at Chaos Group
server as well as the Pipeline
FX server.
So these are really
great solutions
to enable you to be able to
say, hey, I'm a smaller studio.
But I want to compete
with the large studios,
because, as you know,
10 machines for 10 hours
cost the same as 100
machines for one hour.
But there's that nice, nine
hour wall clock difference
that you're saving.
In terms of virtual machines,
it's all the same hardware.
The racks that I showed you
earlier on the Jupiter fabric
page, that's the same
infrastructure that all
of Google services running on.
So Maps, Search, all the
machine learning technology,
everything runs across
the same infrastructure.
We pretty much have
Compute and Storage.
So this is not like a special,
roll your own version for GCP.
This is the industrial
strength stuff
that Google runs everything on.
And because of that, we
have live migration support,
and we're the only
company that has this.
It's the ability to,
basically, snapshot a machine
and move it to another
box on another rack
without interrupting the job.
The live migration even
supports use cases,
such as a file system
that's under heavy load
with local SSD.
We can migrate that file
system while it's running.
And it'll take several
minutes to do it,
but we can actually move it
without interrupting the job.
That gives you huge
amounts of uptime.
That means that we can
fail a power supply,
we can have hard
drives go down, we
can have all sorts
of the usual problems
that one has in a
very large scale data
center without
interrupting the workflow.
So that's a huge advantage
with standard VMs.
The other nice thing is,
from a pricing standpoint,
there's a sustained
use discount.
So if you want to use the
machine five days a week,
but you want to turn
it off on Friday
night through Sunday
afternoon, however
you want to use it,
you only pay the lowest
price at the end of the month.
So the maximum discount is
30% off our standard pricing.
However, if you use it
21 days of the 30 or 31,
you're getting kind
of a 22% to 25%.
So you don't have to
buy in advance or budget
in that regard.
You just pay the lowest price
at the end of the month.
Most of our customers
who are rendering
are taking advantage
of preemptible VMs.
These are the same
VMs that you're
running standard
jobs on, except this
is excess capacity for Google.
Unlike a rendering data
center, where you guys
are running at like 98%
efficiency-- well, 98%
compute usage, I should
say, at all times.
Google runs with higher
margins than that.
And that enables Search
to be highly responsive
and take significant loads.
The scenario for
preemptible VMs, 24 hour
lease, they're 70% off.
So you're paying
$0.30 on the dollar.
To give you an example, that's
32 cores with 120 gigs of RAM,
stood up, including network
and power and spares
is $0.48 an hour.
So that's really inexpensive.
When you do the math on what
the total cost of ownership is,
we're pretty confident that's
a really competitive price.
The machines do get
taken back on occasion
if we need capacity,
or if we need to have
that rack for some reason.
You'll get a 30 second
termination on it.
Integration with your
queuing software,
we'll talk a little more
about how to handle that.
So VM strategies.
So standard VMs, you want to
use that for your gateways,
your Cloud File Systems.
If you have a render
that's more than 24 hours,
please put it on a standard VM.
Do consider use checkpointing
with VRay or PRman or Arnold.
Critical deliveries,
if you absolutely
have to have it tomorrow
at a specific time,
and you don't want to have
the job get interrupted,
potentially, and then
r-spin up a new machine
and start from your
last checkpoint,
there may be a couple--
maybe tens of minutes
or more between
the last checkpoint
and where the machine start.
Preemptible VMs, however,
are fantastic for doing
render's normal work, new comps,
any of that work is fantastic.
I would also encourage
simulation work
to run on standards,
if it's something
that's important to you
in the long running.
Making your queuing software
aware of preemptible VMs.
We have a pub/sub service that
basically looks at the Cloud
log, and you can basically
point your queueing system
at that to look
at whether or not
a machine is going to go down.
If that occurs, we
encourage the scripting
to be such that you send a
termination to the machine
of the job you're running.
So if you can get a
checkpoint out of it, great.
You have 30 seconds
to write the data,
and you're pushing it back
to a cloud file system.
It's usually successful.
You also immediately stop
sending jobs to that machine
if you're bin packing.
So if you have a
32 core machine,
and you're treating it
like an on-prem rental,
you may want to be running
16 cores for render
and some for comp and
some for other jobs.
If that's the case, you
want to stop submitting jobs
to that machine.
You can immediately
spin up another machine.
It's just that we
want that one back.
But we still have
stock elsewhere.
So you get another
machine coming up,
which takes about 45 seconds
to get the machine up,
and then you can start putting
your render executable on it
and loading data into it.
So again, as one
machine goes down,
the next machine comes up.
And you can get pixels back
in roughly under two minutes,
depending how large
your scene is to load.
So in terms of different
workloads that we have,
we're having great
success with people
running rendering workloads.
But we have other customers
who have come to us and said,
hey, we've got a
big effect show,
and it's 10x what we have.
And I'm sure
everyone in this room
has had issues with high
I/O on the local network
where even if you have a
physical caching solution
on-prem, you're
still in a scenario
where-- an example
I can give, you
have hundreds of fluid sims
running at the same time.
I had that on "All You Need is
Kill" was the name of the film.
And "Edge of Tomorrow" was
the final release name.
That final shot
in the Thames, we
had hundreds of naiad fluid
sims going simultaneously.
And it was just crushing
the I/O on the file system.
The caching appliance was
being forced to flush,
because we were
reading huge data sets
and writing 20 to 30 or
more gigs per frame out.
And as a result, we needed
to segment the network
and use a different file system.
So the opportunity to
do that on the Cloud
is significant in the fact
that our network is phenomenal.
And the file system
performance is extremely high.
Compositing, decompositing,
I know the standard workloads
are, it takes too long
to push up normal comps
and then do the minor
compute that's required
and then pull the data down.
However, for decompositing,
because the I/O
is so significant,
we encourage people
to use the Cloud for that,
in the fact that it's really
providing a significant
benefit by not
crushing their local renders.
And for archive use
cases, the ability
to store the data on the Cloud
and have your entire tool
chain from the
previous file, I'm
sure everyone here is
running multiple shows
in their facility,
has disparate versions
of environments and such.
And if you want to
go back and say,
I want to restore that robot
from the previous movie,
but I also need to restore
the entire environment
that it was in.
You can have a snapshot
of that tool chain,
you can have the asset
available to you,
you can get it in
two to seven seconds,
as opposed to a
multi-hour restore
if you have on-prem for LTO,
as well as a multi-day restore
if that file is elsewhere.
So the advantage of
this is it gives you
the ability to let the
artist work immediately.
You can pull just the
files off you want.
You don't have to restore
entire directories.
And you're in a scenario
where, instead of saying,
I need to pull back
20 gigs of something
and realize it was actually
stored in someone's home
directory, you can actually
traverse the file tree
and get just the files you want.
And it's only a penny per gig.
You can also upload
a 400 terabyte show
because you have to get it off
your local file system on-prem.
But then if you have a
little bit of downtime,
you can put a talented
Pipe TA on to the job
and go through and pare
that show down and get it
down to 225, 175 gigs, whatever
you can get that show down to.
Once you've already shipped
it, and it's already
been shown in the theaters, you
can get that minimum archive.
That's hard to do without LTO.
I don't know anyone who's
actually onlined LTO tapes
and then pared them down
before putting them back out.
So the rental model is
what people started with.
The idea was, Bob and
Sarah come by with a truck
and rack up three more racks.
And you plug them in, you
have enough network capacity,
you have cooling and storage,
and physical foot space
for the boxes to sit there.
That's fine.
Your queuing system picks
them up and away you go.
The problem with
that model is that it
doesn't scale as well
as you might like it to.
And in some markets, it's
difficult from a power
standpoint.
It's expensive to get
power here in California.
People often move
to a colo model,
so they can have a
larger physical space
and make better use of
their on-prem facility
to put more artists and such.
Companies in London where
it's super expensive,
they're out of cooling,
and power is a problem.
The problem with this
is it's fixed scale.
The dynamic model is the
one I'm most excited about
and the fact that this is
the wall clock savings.
So if you run a significant
number of machines
for a short period
of time, because we
have permanent billing
after the first 10 minutes,
the cost is going to
be the same to you
if you run 1,000 machines
in a 24 hour period
as if you run 4,000 machines
in a six hour period.
But the difference
is is that the comp
is able to work on
that file tonight.
And the lighting artist doesn't
have to come in tomorrow
and say, yeah,
it's on [INAUDIBLE]
but it's still on the farm.
You never have it
still on the farm.
You're able to get
the shots through.
And when you save a couple of
days of production time, that's
the effects time, that's
producer time, all
the different soups, leads.
That's a significant per
day cost that you're saving.
Here are some of the customers
that we're working with.
Some of them are local.
Some of them are
global in presence.
Framestore had a really
great success with us.
They were one of our
earlier customers.
They workee-- well, they put a
really great system, I think.
They were running between
6,000 and 12,000 cores.
And they were one of our early
of year launch customers,
as well.
Tristan, from Framestore,
participated in a webinar
last fall.
And he talked about being at
roughly 2.6 gig, sustained
throughput on a 3 gig
link from SOHO net
that could scale to 10.
Once they put the
Avere cache in place,
they were down about
1.1 to 1.2 gig.
So that would enable
them to either double
the number of cores
on a fixed pipe size
or be able to work with
a significant reduction
in throughput, as
well, and still
maintain the same
number of cores.
So one of things I just
want to talk briefly about
is the total cost of ownership.
And for us, I have performance
on one side and cost over time.
And this example is just
a 36 month amortization.
So the on-premise is, let's
say, for fun, you go out
and you buy 5,000 cores on-prem.
The performance is
going to be the same.
They will render the same
amount over that period of time.
So by the 36th month,
if you're paying
for it per month, the
cost for the cores
are the same, your per monthly
cost if you financed it.
And the performance is the same.
With Google, our prices go down.
We have a Moore's
law of pricing.
So we're doing reductions on
a more frequent basis than 18
months, but we're pretty much
doing the half every 18 months.
So the price will be
significantly less three years
in the future than it is today.
But the cool thing
is, is that you
get the architectural
increases over time.
So you'd go from Sandy
Bridge, Ivy Bridge,
you're doing to Haswell, all
the way to Skylake, Ice Lake.
You can look at the
future architectures.
So on this graph, you can see
that your performance is going
to go up several
architectures worth,
and your cost is
going to be down.
And the nice thing
is is you're only
paying for this for the
minutes you're using it.
If you have a slowdown
in production,
if you go back
into story, if they
want to shoot pick ups, whatever
that is, you can shut it off.
If you've prepaid for
compute, then you're
in a story where you're just
paying for it whether you're
using it or not.
And that's a completely
different model.
So we're getting really
good adoption with this.
So Production Safety Valve.
This is the idea that
we work with customers,
and we get a proof of concept in
before the project gets crazy.
I have had calls on a
Friday afternoon saying,
we're delivering Monday.
We're crushed.
Can you help us?
And then you scramble
over the weekend
to try and set something up.
We can often do that.
It depends on the complexities.
It's so much nicer when
you're involved in advance.
The account managers have
some credits available so
that people can start.
And most importantly,
it's all about being
able to make a single picture.
As long as you can get a gateway
set up, get your VPN set up,
and you can either do
an NFS mount, depending
on where you're located.
For here, we encourage
a Cloud File System.
You can go with just
a simple single load
filer or a persistent
disk to do a quick test.
You upload a self-contained
scene, you can render a frame.
We do encourage
everybody to identify
the machines they have on-prem.
So I'm sure
everybody in the room
has four or five
generations in their data
center of different
machines that they
have on-prem plus a couple
different generations
of workstations, depending on
what artists are using them.
I encourage people
to go and take
a scene that's
self-contained so we
can get network network
performance for storage
out of the game.
Put the local file
on the machine.
Do a render of it.
If it takes 20 minutes
or an hour, that's fine.
Put a weight on that.
And put that in a
spreadsheet and say,
the middle machine was a 1.0.
Run them on your fast machines
and your slower machines,
and come back with a number.
Then benchmark all
the cloud providers.
Benchmark Google.
And go through and try our
different architectures.
We currently have
three available,
Sandy Bridge, Ivy Bridge.
We have Haswell.
You can imagine Broadwell
may be coming soon.
In that context,
the ability to say,
this job will take 55
minutes on our bare metal,
and it'll take this
long on the Cloud.
That really helps from
a scheduling standpoint
and from a cost standpoint.
Otherwise, it's
like, well, hold on.
That machine, the 32
[INAUDIBLE] box, $0.48 an hour,
but how does that equate?
That also enables you to put
a cost on your local render
and say, this machine under
the artist workstation, that
has a Quadro 6,000 in it.
That's not an in-- it's a great
card, but it's not inexpensive.
And there's tons of cores.
That box takes up physical
space and requires
spares and s-cooling, and
you guys know the drill.
The opportunity to be able to
say to production, your render
cost tonight is going
to be this much.
Even though you're using
our on-prem, it's not free.
I know it's rolled
into the facility cost.
But you can start attributing
it to shows so that they say,
fine.
We're going to give up
some of this for local.
Or we're going to borrow this.
We're going to take some
cloud compute and get
the shot done more quickly.
The ability to be
able to, again,
expand to other types of
workflow such as simulation
and comp, really exciting
because of the file I/O savings
that you get on that.
So please, start early.
We're happy to help
you get set up.
For those who do transcoding,
we have the fantastic partners
we have here.
We also have FFmpeg
which is open source.
YouTube is based on that.
We have a cool pipeline that you
can use with Qube or Deadline.
Or you can roll
your own, or we'll
use Tractor that enables
you to spin up a VM,
copy the file
locally, and then be
able to perform the transcode
using our local SSD,
and then make 28
different flavors of it
in different codecs and
different bitrates and such.
But today, we actually have
an announcement for you.
Still in beta, not a
public announcement,
but for this room, we have
Colorfront's transcoder
running on our platform.
So it's still in beta.
It works very well.
So we have a couple
of initial customers
we're working with
who are running
production workloads on it.
But it's a really cool
professional transcoder
that'll do ProRes, and
everything else you want,
running on our platform.
So thank you very
much for being here.
I'll be available to chat
afterwards and answer any
questions you may have or
point you to someone who knows
the answer, if I don't.
With that said, we
have Aaron from Avere
who will be joining
us virtually.
And is Aaron on board?
Yes?
I'm getting a thumbs up.
Here comes the big screen.
AARON WETHEROLD: Can
you hear me, Jeff?
JEFF KEMBER: Yes, we can, Aaron.
Thanks for joining us today.
AARON WETHEROLD: Great.
So that's a perfect intro.
I appreciate the intro there.
So what we wanted
to do today was
kind of give you sort of a
brief introduction to how
we would deploy the Virtual FXT
within Google Compute Engine.
And what that sort of
deployment from a installation
configuration looks like.
So just to give a little
bit of background on myself,
I've been with the company
for almost seven years now.
And I'm focused on
the virtual platforms.
So if you start
deploying, or you
start talking to us about
deploying a Virtual FXT,
you'll probably see
me at some point.
Probably the same talking head
set up in a leather chair,
but maybe, hopefully, face to
face at some point as well.
So I don't know if you guys
have the slides up there.
Hopefully, yes.
I can see the slides.
I can see myself.
OK, there we go.
So we just wanted to go
through some of the steps
that we'll typically
do within a deployment.
And then I'll do a demo of what
we call our Cluster Manager.
And we'll take a look at
what the infrastructure looks
like running within GC itself.
So as Jeff mentioned,
we start out typically
with a three node cluster.
And each of these
nodes in Avere node
is going to be sitting on
a instance type within GCE.
And today, we support highmen-8
and highmen-32 instance types.
And then we have a couple--
or a few different-- storage
options.
So on the persistent side,
we'll support either one or four
terabytes of persistent SSD.
Or on the local SSD
side, we'll support
one and a half terabytes.
And that's per instance.
And again, we start
out with a FXT cluster
that's three nodes in size.
And then as you need
additional throughput,
you just add one node at a time
until you get to the desired
throughput and I/O levels.
So for a deployment
within GCP, obviously
you will need a
project to install in.
We'll typically talk to you.
But make sure that you have--
from a quota point of view,
if you just opened
up your project,
you may need to add
some additional quota
for either persistent
SSD or instance type,
depending on how many
nodes you're spinning up.
And then we do have a couple
of infrastructure instances
that we bring up.
So the first one is going
to be a NAT instance.
And we use that to route API
calls and any S3 calls out
to GCS storage.
So the reason why
we have to have that
is that API is accessible
basically from internet side.
So within your project
and within your subnet,
we just need to be able
to issue those API calls.
And we use those for things
like, when we do HA failovers,
if we're moving an IP from
one instance to another,
for example, we want to be able
to move that IP transparently
so that the workload continues
even in the face of an instance
failure.
And we can do all that if
we have access to the API.
Obviously, to create
instances within the cluster,
we would need to
do that as well.
So the next thing that we do is
we modify the firewall rules.
We're actually
using an IP address
space that's typically above
what gets assigned by Google.
And the reason why
we do that is we're
using more IPs than the
Google API will typically
provide for an instance.
And I'll show you a chart
of what that looks like,
a little graphic of that.
Then the next step
is we bring up
what's called the
Cluster Manager, which
is another instance.
And that gives you the
graphical user interface
for actually
deploying the system.
And I'll show you
that within the demo.
The next step is we
go through-- we use
that UI to create the cluster.
Then we basically UI
into the Virtual FXT.
Once it's configured, we
complete the configuration.
And from that point, you're
ready to mount your clients
and start your
workload against it.
So if we'll go to
the next slide,
I'll show you what that looks
like from a graphical point
of view.
So within GCP, you
have your project.
You'll see we have a firewall
rule that's allowing both--
in this case, there
was a 10.241--
10.240 IP address
space slash 16.
And then we're going to use
the subnet above that, which
is 10.241 to add IPs into it
And you can see here we have
three other virtual FXTs.
We have, what I call
here, the Shepherd,
which is the Cluster Manager.
And then the NAT
box which is sitting
there routing any
traffic that needs
to go out to the API space.
So the next thing that
I'd like to do then
is show you that Cluster
Manager and actually
go through the process
of deploying a system.
So let me quickly share
out via screen share.
So hopefully you all
can see that now.
Can someone give me a thumbs up
if they can-- verbal thumbs up.
I can't hear anything,
so hopefully it's
either really quiet
or the audio dropped.
JEFF KEMBER: We can hear you.
AARON WETHEROLD: Perfect,
thank you so much.
JEFF KEMBER: No problem.
AARON WETHEROLD: So
here we have a project,
and I'm just showing you here
the infrastructure piece.
So we've got what we call the
shepherd, which is our Cluster
Manager, and the NAT gateway.
And we'll see those running.
I also have a client that I have
connected to our FXT clusters
already running.
So what I'm going
to do here is I'm
going to connect into
the Cluster Manager
and show you the user
interface for that.
So here you can see I've
got the user interface.
I've got one cluster
that's up and running.
This is going to be
like a cooking show
where I create the
vFXT, and then I'm
going to jump to that
one because I don't want
to sit here telling
jokes for 12 minutes
while the cluster
actually creates.
But I do want to go through
the UI for the creation.
So when we create a
virtual FXT, you're
basically logged in to
our Cluster Manager.
And now I'm going to
create a new cluster.
So I'll just give it a
name, Four, and a password
for the user interface.
Now, I can choose
the region that I
want to deploy in and
also the instance type.
So again, I have a choice
of highmen-8 or 32.
And then I can pick the number
of nodes that I start out with.
So I'm just going to
start out with three.
In this case, I'm going to
add local SSD as the option.
So this is basically
all the information
that I need now to
create that cluster.
And what the
system's going to do,
once I hit the Create vFXT
cluster, is it will go out.
It creates a job.
And now the shepherd,
you can see here.
We've got Start
Up under Creation.
And it goes through the
steps of actually deploying
those instances.
So you can see that we're
connected to the Google API.
It's setting up the three
different networks that we're
using within that subnet.
It'll go out, retrieve the
image that we shared out
with your project, create a
root disk-- actually create
a template for the
instances, then instantiate
each of the three instances,
the virtual FXT instances,
and join them into the cluster.
So that when this
is complete, you
have a fully
functioning FXT cluster.
And so this typically takes
about 10 to 12 minutes.
Like I said, I'm not
going to wait for that.
But I'm just going to
jump to the cluster that's
already created.
And you can see
here all the steps
that the system went through.
So it actually goes
through, gives you
the IP addresses
that it's using,
assigns those, pulls in the
image, creates the instance,
creates a snapshot
of the template
that it's going to be using.
And then it creates the
additional two other instances
and then joins them
into a cluster.
At the same time, we're also
connecting to a GCS bucket.
So that's going to be provided
automatically, ready to go.
It gets junctioned
into a namespace,
and then it's immediately
accessible via NFS
once the cluster is created.
So as we go through
here, it will tell you
what each node is using from
an IP address space, updates
the software if it
needs to, and then
gives you the IP address
of the management UI
so that you can login.
So that's the cluster
as it's created.
When you're complete,
you'll actually
have that system up and running.
And then you can
use that management
IP to log into the system.
And this is the virtual FXT.
That's that one that we
created that's running.
As I mentioned, it
has what we call
a core filer, which
is your back end
storage, which is a GCS bucket.
And its junctioned
into slash GCS.
So here I have a
client that's already
connected-- that was connecting
to it, running some load.
You can see in the
last half hour,
we've actually got some load
running through that system.
In a full name space,
accessible via NFS and SMB
tied to that GCS
bucket and ready
to accelerate the workload.
From this point, and this
is what the cluster actually
gives you by default,
then you could connect
either additional
GCS buckets, you
could connect to
a NAS device that
may be sitting over the WAN
that's directly on-premise.
And you can pull that in
accessible via your VPN.
Whatever you need to to
actually create the system
that's going to actually serve
for your specific workload
or your specific needs.
So I'm going to stop here,
because my colleague Jim
Thompson an SE that handles
media and entertainment
for Avere, he's
actually there today.
And he's going to continue
with the portion of the UI
demonstration.
So Jim, I'll go back to you.
JIM THOMPSON: Thanks, Aaron.
So what I have here is-- once
we get it up on the screen.
Oh, by the way,
I'm Jim Thompson.
I've been at Avere
for I think maybe
two more months than Aaron.
I don't know if
Aaron's still on live.
But we had an argument
a couple years ago,
who was which employee number.
And I think I beat him by
maybe two employee numbers.
I think I was number
21, he was number 23.
Anyways, I've been
at Avere a long time.
And I cover the media
entertainment, vertical domain.
I cover all the west coast as
well as Australia, New Zealand.
So what I'm going to
do today is I'm going
to walk through the Avere UI.
What I have here is a
couple virtual machines
running on my laptop here
within VMware Fusion.
So I've created a one
instance, one cluster node
Avere caching layer.
And I have-- let's
see if I can--
I also have a Linux NAS box
as well as my MacBook Pro here
is acting as a client.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to walk through some of the-- we
could spend a lot of time here,
but I'm just going
to walk through some
of the highlights of the UI.
So this is-- like Aaron showed
before-- this is the dashboard.
And you would probably, once
you create an Avere cluster,
you're going to spend
most of your time here.
Not too often you'll
be messing around
with settings, the other tabs.
I'll go through them,
but the dashboard
is where you're going to gain
most of your information.
And if we spend a
little bit of time here,
you can take a look
at-- this is obviously
what's happening today
for your clients.
I don't have a client.
I could show some
traffic, but it's
going to be just playing
AC/DC or something.
I don't know if we want to
listen to that right now.
But nonetheless, I can take
a look at the ops per second.
I can also change this
to the throughput.
And I could also
bring up latency.
And again, this
is client facing.
What I also can do is I
can take a look at-- drill
down into either a
cluster wide view,
or I can take a
view of the Vserver.
Now what a Vserver is is
just a virtual representation
of whatever NAS product
you have sitting behind us,
or whatever object
storage device you have,
which could be GCP as
well as something on-prem.
Could be object storage on-prem,
or it could be a NAS on-prem.
But I can actually define what I
want to look at here, depending
on what I'm interested in at
that particular point in time.
I can change this
time for the dashboard
to be-- my default's
five minutes.
I can, as you can see here, I
can make it whatever I want.
I could also select a date and
time which can be interesting.
Say I want to look at
something from maybe two, three
weeks ago, four weeks ago,
this goes back in time
until you last rebooted the
cluster or did an install.
So there's a point where it
actually removes some of the--
or writes over some of the data.
Let's just go put this
back at five minutes.
The chart controls here
we can take a look at.
We can change the colors
on the ops per second.
We have client ops which is,
obviously we know what that is.
It's the clients
doing operations
into the Avere cluster.
This is the source.
So I could change that
depending on what I have.
And I can actually change
these colors if I-- for myself,
I'm slightly color blind, so I
might pick something that where
I can actually read it.
But data management
ops is the operations
that we use for-- we have
a couple features called
Move and Mirror,
FlashMove and FlashMirror.
So those are the
data management ops
that you would see there if
we were actually moving data
from one particular
core filer-- which,
again, is the storage
repository-- to another storage
repository.
Say you want to move from your
local NAS box up through us
into an object storage into
GCP, or GCS, pardon me.
On the bottom of
the dashboard, we
have a couple
things that we need
to make note of which
is the conditions.
So these conditions could
be either red or yellow.
Red would be,
obviously, an alert,
and you'd want to
definitely take
a look at that immediately.
If it's yellow, it's not
too much of a concern.
The conditions should
usually clear by themselves.
If they don't, then we want
to take a closer look at it.
The alerts is just
what it is, alert.
And what we have here
is-- just before you
guys came, and I
added the core filer
which was my Linux NAS box.
And of course, it gave me
a couple of alerts here
that-- I had actually removed it
last night when I was testing.
So the virtual server,
again, the virtual server's
is Avere's representation
of what these core
files are sitting behind us.
We have one Vserver,
which is presenting
all of the core filers
sitting behind us
into a global namespace.
So that means that
each individual export
from the core filers represented
with a junction point.
And I'll show you that when
we get into the settings.
The Vserver has a group
of client facing IPs.
We also have a cluster
group of IPs as well.
The client facing IPs,
we'd usually-- it's
up to the customer to
roll into a round robin
DNS name to have the
clients mount it.
And they would be pseudo
balancing once at a time.
This is the core filer.
Again, this is my Linus machine.
I have this Linux machine set
in read only mode or re-caching
where rights are pass through.
I have a verification with
the core filer at 30 seconds.
So what this is--
the Avere caching
layers is essentially
a client to a NAS box.
And then, in turn,
we're also servers.
So this verification
of 30 seconds
is the same as what a client
NFS attribute time will be,
which would be 30 seconds by
default. I can change that.
The reason I have this.
This is my default
set up in case
you have clients that could
be accessing the storage
device directly instead
of going through us.
So Avere caching layer needs
to go back and stat the file
system for everything that
we have in cache to make sure
that we have the latest.
OK.
Again, I only have one node.
I could add a node, but
this give some information,
some good information.
It shows the IPs that
are client facing.
For my global namespace,
it gives some performance
specs such as the ops per
second and the hit rate.
Of course, the hit rate is--
I don't know why it's 50%.
I'm not sure about that.
There's no activity going
on, but nonetheless.
And then the performance.
We also have a tab here for
clients, hot files, and cache.
We're not going to see
much here, because I only
have one client.
And this client is
actually my MacBook,
which is through a NAT
device so it's not really
picking up true IP for it.
But we would see
a list of IPs that
would be your clients if
this was something live.
And then the hot
files is interesting.
That will give you a whole
list of the hot files
at any particular point in time
and give you the full path.
So this is the
full path to a file
that I was actually accessing
not too long ago, which
is when I was playing AC/DC.
Just to wake up this
morning, because there
was no coffee left, so.
This is as a new tab that
we just put into the UI.
And it tells the amount
of space that we're
using four reads, writes,
total use space, free space,
et cetera.
And this is kind of
interesting, especially
when you have a couple different
core filers sitting behind us.
Every core filer that
we proxy, we actually
attribute a certain level
of cache in their DRAM,
as well as the next tier which
would be SSD or SaaS drives,
depending on the physical box.
If it's a virtual
instance, then it's
mostly going to be SSD, the
local SSD or the durable.
So that's the most exciting tab.
I'm going to go through
some more boring things here
in a couple seconds.
But nonetheless,
the analytic page
is probably the next
more exciting tab.
What it does is it takes
the dashboard information.
And you can actually kind of
extrapolate that and drill down
a little bit deeper.
So we can take a look at
client facing latency.
We can actually go back in time
using this slider bar here,
which is interesting.
And then we have, these
are canned graphs.
You see ops per second,
which we had before.
But this is just a little
bit easier to view.
And what we can do with this,
we can create any type of graph
we want.
So we can add a
graph to the set,
or we can actually
create a new set.
But you can actually--
so I'm going
to call those client
stats, and I'm
going to choose the
data that I want.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to scroll down
and pick something
that's interesting to us.
Maybe we'll do ops in
the client network.
And then what I can do
is I can break this out.
Say I'm mostly interested in
maybe access calls, lookup
calls, and get adders,
and read your pluses.
And then I can create this.
I've used this actually a
number of different times
in troubleshooting
some problems.
So it can be really
flexible and really,
really important to actually
create these and create
different graph sets.
And just pop in there
and take a look at it.
So you think there's some
kind of high latency going on,
is your core filer, for
some particular reason,
and we can kind of
drill down into this.
So this is the Settings tab.
I'm not sure if Aaron--
Aaron might have
touched on this a little bit.
There's a lot here.
There's probably no reason to
go through everything here.
But nonetheless, we'll go
over some of the basic things
that we've done.
So there's sections here.
There's a Vserver which
again, this is the Avere
GNS that I created.
This is a representation of all
those other NAS devices sitting
behind us, or optic
storage devices.
Then we have the core filer
section, which is again,
you're basically
defining the core filer
prior to creating a
virtual server from that.
And the cluster network is
basic management stuff, general
set up, and a few other things.
And the last one
is administration.
You would go down here
to actually update
the software on it or actually
perform some maintenance
on the cluster.
One of the things under the
cluster section that we usually
spend a lot of time with,
other than the tab which
had FXT nodes in the dashboard,
you can drill down a little bit
deeper here.
Usually this will give you a
little bit more information
once we have activity,
but you can actually
do some activities here.
I can change the
name of this node
if I want or nodes
within the cluster.
And it'll also
list-- I'll go back.
But since I clicked
on this node,
it gives me information
about the node.
One, I don't have
IPMI connected.
Of course, this
is not a hardware.
This is a virtual machine.
There's no IPA.
But nonetheless,
here's the client
facing IPs and other
performance information.
And then at the bottom, it
will tell you the connections
that I have back to my NAS box.
And of course some
other information
about the networking.
If I were to-- if
there were nodes--
say I had to expand
my existing cluster,
whether it's a
virtual or bare metal,
it would show the
lists of FXT nodes
that were waiting
to join in here.
So this is how easy it
is to actually spin up
another Avere cluster.
And actually, we'll see if we
can-- not sure how long this
is going to take to boot
up, but nonetheless, it'll
be fun to see if we can do this.
I'm just spinning up another
virtual machine here.
And while that's
coming up, we'll
move around to- we'll step
through this a little bit more.
So this is my Vserver
that I have created.
I've named it Avere-GNS.
All right, there it is there.
I can hit this to
create a new one,
or I can suspend this
one for whatever reason,
or I can remove this.
So I want to just get
rid of the cluster,
or for whatever reason, I don't
have that NAS, that core filer,
I need to remove the
virtual server first.
And then I need to remove
the core filer second.
This is just details
for that virtual server.
The namespace is
something else that's
probably actually one of
the more interesting pieces
that you need to deal with.
So in order-- I mentioned
this before-- in order
to create a virtual server
and have it represented,
I have to have a junction
point to represent
those exports or that
bucket or container
from an object storage device.
So this is what I've done here.
I've actually created
the namespace with /vol.
I could call it whatever.
I can add a new junction here.
Let's call it vol2.
And I know that because
I know that there's
another export from my NAS box.
I'm just defining
the core filer here.
And if you have a
number of exports,
it's going to show
up in this list here.
So I already have a
junction point for vol1.
I'm going to create
one for vol2.
And then I'm going
to submit that.
OK, so now I have two
different directors
under the top level,
vol1 and vol2.
And I could potentially
just go ahead
and mount that from a
client without any problem.
This is where I change my export
policies if I need to do that.
You probably would.
This is where we
create the rules.
Once I create the policies,
I would apply those.
So for SMB, I would
want to go into here.
There's a few other
modifications and settings
that we would need to do for
creating a SIs or SMB share.
And this is the
manage core filer.
So I mentioned before,
we have Vserver
which is the proxy definition
for the core filer.
This is where I would
define a core filer.
I have to define some
type of storage device,
we call it a core filer, that
sits behind us, some storage
repository before I
actually roll something
into my namespace and
create a junction point.
And that's about it.
We could see if this
guy has-- it has.
OK, so what I did, I booted
my second virtual machine up.
So I would click this to
add it to the cluster.
[INAUDIBLE] promise me.
One thing I need
to make sure is I
need to have enough
IPs to accommodate
this particular node.
And I know that I do.
I know there was client facing
as well as cluster facing.
And in a few minutes,
this'll come up.
And it'll show up in the
first part of the screen,
so you'll have node
one and node two.
But that's how easy it is to add
another node into the cluster.
That's all I got.
Next, we have Simon from SADA.
He's going to come up and speak.
SIMON MARGOLIS: All right.
Can you guys hear me?
Yeah, there we go.
So good morning, everybody.
So my name is Simon Margolis.
I'm the director of our
Cloud Platform Practice
here at SADA Systems.
I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about what value
we bring to this
whole process and how
we can help sort of orchestrate
the entirety of using
GCP and better adopting
it for your workloads.
So first of all, a little bit
about who SADA Systems is.
We've been doing this
for about 16 years now.
We started in 2000.
I've been with the company
for about five years now.
I actually founded this business
back about four years ago
when GCP was in beta still.
But we've been having a lot of
fun breaking things since then.
Obviously things are a
whole lot more stable now.
We've moved, in total,
10 million users
over to various Google products
across the numerous pieces
of our Google for Work business.
And I'll talk a little bit
more about that as we move on.
We've been a Google partner
since the year 2007.
We've been a Google for
Work premier partner
since they announced
that program,
meaning that we're
able to provide
our customers a little bit more
white glove treatment, little
bit more handholding to really
help you get the job done.
In terms of the
solutions that we offer,
we work across the
Google for Work spectrum.
So we're not just a GCP shop,
although that's all I focus on.
We do apps, we do Maps, we
do Search, of course GCP,
as well as Chrome devices.
And we offer a
number of services.
So we are, at the
core of our business,
a systems integrator
and a consultant.
We like to work with you,
get to know your business,
and help you navigate this
network of products and options
and offerings to make sure
what we're offering you
makes the best sense
for what you're
trying to accomplish from
many angles of your business,
not just IT.
And that also involves,
often cases, training,
change management, and of
course, manage services.
We have a number of
offerings based here in LA.
And I'll talk a little
bit more about that.
But before we get to that,
we'll talk a little bit
about why work with us and sort
of what makes SADA special.
So we're consistently ranked
as one of the best places
to work by the LA
Business Journal.
We're based here in Los Angeles,
and we're very proud of that.
We have a great
corporate culture,
and we try to exude that
to our customers as well.
We've won the Google Maps for
Work Global Partner of the Year
award, I want to say three
years consecutively now,
definitely the last two.
We try to replicate that same
level of excellence across all
of our practices as well.
We've also been the
North America Partner
of the Year for a few
years for Google Apps,
just to exemplify
how we definitely
strive to bring the
best to our customers
across all of our product lines.
So why work with SADA?
So first of all, like
I mentioned earlier,
we are a Premier Partner
across all of Google for Work.
Why that's important
is we're able to offer
holistic solutions that
aren't just focused
in one area or another.
We can build workloads that
involve Maps APIs, that
involve Google Cloud Platform,
that involve Google apps, so
on and so forth, to make sure
that whatever we're providing
to you makes the most sense
for what your business needs,
regardless of where it falls
into the various product
categories.
Also, we're based in LA, were
founded in North Hollywood.
We still have our
headquarters up there,
and we're close to you.
We like to come on-site.
We like to get to know our
customers as much as possible.
And so we're also able to offer
a 24 by 7 LA-based support
desk.
This is important,
because when you call us,
you're going to
get somebody who's
sitting in North Hollywood.
You're going to get somebody
who's probably somebody
you've spoken with before.
And our team is going
to know your business,
is going to know the
problems that you face often.
And we'll know your
deployment, know your goals,
and we'll be able
to help you better
than calling into,
say, a call center
and speaking to a
new person every time
you have to submit some
type of trouble request.
We're able to help
you right away.
We're also-- because we're
all in the same office,
our help desk is able to work
with our engineering team,
work with our consultants,
work with our trainers,
and really provide more than
just a Tier-1 or Tier-2 support
experience.
We can really help
consult and navigate
where you're trying to
go with whatever problems
you're facing.
And then finally, one of the
main reasons that customers
like to work with
SADA Systems is
because we quarterback the
entirety of the GCP deployment.
And so you saw a number
of great speakers
today talk about a number of
different options and routes
you can go with within GCP.
We are able to sort of
service that pivot point
and navigate the
community of Googlers,
navigate the community of
fantastic technology partners
that you've heard from
today, and really prescribe
the best solution
based on everything
that's out there for what
you are trying to accomplish.
And if we don't have
an exact solution,
we can help you look at all the
solutions that are out there
and work through it
together and figure out
what makes the best sense.
We have a number of
customers-- like I said,
we've been doing
this for a few years
now, since everything
was in beta.
So we've seen a lot of things.
How they can go right,
how they can go wrong.
And we like to sort of
cut the learning curve
as short as possible
and help you
get to where you want to
be as quickly as possible.
So as you can see, I'll skip
through this pretty quickly.
I know we're short on time.
We work with a few pretty big
logos you might recognize.
And there's definitely a lot
more than what's on this slide
here.
Just gives you an
idea of the quality
and scale of the customers
we like to work with.
And again, in the
effort to save time,
I will be around after this.
If anyone has any
questions, I'd love
to chit chat about
specific use cases,
or how we can help you
really accomplish anything
in particular.
And thank you so much.
Next, we have Todd from Google.
He's going to talk a
little bit about security.
TODD PRIVES:
Everyone can hear me?
Great.
First of all, thanks for coming.
I know this is a very early
morning as far as LA Post goes.
Some really good news,
there will be more coffee
momentarily, or if
it's not already
here-- it might already be here.
So if you get up in the
middle of my presentation
and get coffee, I will
totally understand it.
So I'm Todd Prives.
I am the Product Manager for
Rendering on Google Cloud
Platform.
So my responsibility really
falls to all of the product
roadmap things we're developing.
So as Jeff spoke about
earlier, we have Zync.
And there's some
additional API things
we'll be looking at developing
in the second half of the year
to help larger studios,
such as yourselves,
migrate more easily to
Google Cloud Platform.
But in terms of
today's overview,
I really want to
talk specifically
about security on Google Cloud
Platform, both holistically
what we've done
as well as things
we've addressed
specifically for the feature
film and sensitive television
commercial content industry.
And as Jeff mentioned when
he was up here speaking,
we got together at the beginning
of the year or when he joined.
There was a list of what are the
major things that are blockers.
Obviously licensing
came up, and we
have some solutions for that.
We'll very likely be offering
more of a holistic offering
in the future.
But another really
critical thing is security.
A lot of you are working on
very sensitive, pre-release,
theatrical projects.
And there's the issue around
what studios will and will not
let you put on Google
Cloud Platform.
So I'd like to spend
a few minutes today
talking about our cloud
security and giving you
an overview and an education
as to what we're doing.
So over the last
several years, we've
really seen a shift from the
public perception of Cloud
not necessarily being as secure
as your on-premise environment
to a flip-flop where
Cloud is really
the standard for security.
When you look at the major
public cloud providers,
and Google being one
of them, of course,
it is our business
to protect user data.
We have billions of users
both on the enterprise
and on the individual level.
And maintaining the
integrity of that data
is really critical and
core to our business.
So as you can see here,
these are typically
a lot of the types of
breaches that happen
in on-premise environments.
And we've seen some pretty
high profile breaches.
You can see up there
Sony, Target, Home Depot,
and Ashley Madison
happen in which user data
has been exposed to the public.
So what we have at
Google is really
the end to end supply chain.
We build our own servers.
We write the
hypervisor software.
We lay the groundwork
for the fibre.
This is all integrated
in a single offering
that Google Cloud Platform now
makes publicly available to you
as the user.
And keep in mind from
a holistic overview,
Google Cloud Platform is
the same infrastructure
that powers Google.
So when I talk about
the need for Google
as a corporation to
protect user data,
it's not just on the
enterprise level where
you might be using it for
rendering or for transcoding
or for storage.
But it is the very
fabric of what keeps
Google running as a company.
And in terms of
the different steps
we take to build this end to
end solution, secure solution,
it really starts
with our people.
We have over 500 security
professionals, many of whom
literally have like written
the book on security.
And these people are
employed by Google.
We are the first
company to start
offering a Reward Vulnerability
Program to incentivize people
to try to break us, to
try to find loopholes
and addressing those
and fixing those.
And if you think about
Google, again, as a platform,
we are among the most targeted
platforms in the world.
And that goes everywhere from
nation-state-sponsored attacks
all the way down to
the individual hacker
sitting in their basement
trying to get through.
So critical to our
operation as a business
is the security aspect of it.
So I've spoken a little bit
about the people aspect of it.
From a literal, physical, data
center security standpoint,
there's actually a video
that's up on YouTube
showing the advanced access
restrictions we have.
It's fully biometric.
Myself, as a Google employee, I
cannot get into a data center.
These things are
very locked down,
very restricted in terms of who
actually has physical access
to even operate within
these data centers.
And then, again,
we build the stack.
We're one of the top five
server manufacturers.
We build the hardware,
labeled the hypervisor,
we've laid the network.
Everything end to end
is controlled by Google.
So what are we doing on the
broader scale for security?
Well, these are all the
typical security certifications
that you would see, stuff like
ISO 2701, SOC 2, SOC 3, FISMA,
HIPAA, et cetera.
And you can go to
cloud.google.com/security
to read up more about the things
we're doing within the broader
security spectrum.
But I understand what's really
important for all of you
in this room is how
are we addressing
the studio specific
requirements of Cloud
in today's environment.
And there are several
things we've done.
And I'll walk you through
those on a step by step basis.
I think it's important to note--
and most of you in the room,
I think, are aware of this, to
understand the MPAA's position
on Cloud.
So while they have published
a best practices guideline
for Cloud, there is
currently no certification.
There is no MPAA logo program.
Undergoing an audit for Cloud
with the MPAA does not get you
clearance with the studios.
So we've spoken to
the MPAA about this.
But what we've decided to do
is work directly and closely
with the studios, directly to
educate them about Google Cloud
Platform, inform them of
our security and compliance,
and in some cases,
actually undergo
an independent third party audit
at the request of the studios
to certify Google Cloud
Platform for Tier-1
pre-release theatrical content.
So I think the
important thing to note
is that we've examined
the issues here.
We've examined where
is the real value
in having security audits.
I think we've started at the
top with the most difficult
and strict studios
as far security
goes, and have now taken
that information, taken
that certification, and are
working with the other studios
to essentially vet out
Google Cloud Platform.
And again, this is not going
to be an open the floodgates
to everyone.
As this is a very
new technology,
we know studios are somewhat
hesitant to embrace us.
And they're worried about leaks.
We're talking about billion
dollar tent-pole films and data
getting out.
It really is now on
a case by case basis.
But it's important to understand
how closely we are working
with these studios, how
we're working to provide
prescriptive hardening
guides to show
the implementation
of your pipeline
on Google Cloud
Platform to enable
pre-release theatrical
rendering happening.
And as part of the
work we've been doing,
there's some things
we'll be publishing
by the end of this
quarter on our website.
And all of this material is
now available directly to you.
You can contact Lauren, and
she has access to all of this
and can provide this
to you ahead of time.
But we will be providing
this independent audit
that we've undergone showing how
we map to the MPAA standards.
So again, while not necessarily
giving us the ability
to get a Cloud Certification
through the MPAA,
this is at least
showing how we do map
to those standards
for any of you
that are concerned about that.
And we'll also be publishing a
best practices hardening guide
for how to safely and securely
deploy your cloud rendering
solution on Google
Cloud Platform.
So in the end,
this is really all
about giving you, the
customers, control
over your security while at the
same time understanding that
within this industry
specifically,
there are definite requirements
and needs and relationships
that need to be maintained
with the Big Six studios who
are giving you much
of your work when it
comes to feature film content.
And I'm confident to say that
we've done a great job so far.
And I'm really looking
forward to a lot
of the things we'll
be able to talk about
as the year progresses
in terms of projects
done on GCP for major
feature film releases.
So next, I am going to turn
it over to our panelists.
I believe Jeff
Kember from Google
will be up, along with
Jim Thompson from Avere.
And I'd also like to introduce
the folks from Eight VFX who
are going to speak.
So we'll go ahead and
get the chairs set up
and start our panel
in just a moment.
JEFF KEMBER: Hey, guys.
And just while we're
getting the chairs set up,
there's just one thing
I wanted to point out.
So Google does not
have an official GPU
offering at this time.
But what we do have is an
interest in hearing from you on
do you want them?
If you do, come see me after.
And let me know if you want
compute GPUs, or display GPUs,
how many you might want,
how you might use them.
We're just kind of
taking some information.
So we have a little survey
that we can send you,
as well, that you can fill
out a little more concrete.
So again, as we all know,
most of the compute loads
are render on CPU, but there
are remote desktop workloads
and other magic things
that happen well on a GPU.
So please come and talk
with me after the show.
Or actually, can I
see a show of hands?
Who's interested in GPUs?
OK, that's pretty good.
I like that.
In fact, I want
to take a picture
of that for the Product Manager
because he asked me to ask.
So hands up again, please.
Awesome, OK, and got it.
Thank you very much.
TODD PRIVES: OK, so we now
have our panel discussion.
I'd like to bring
Jeff Kember back
on stage, Jim Thompson, and
Damien, and Philippe from Eight
VFX.
Who have actually gone ahead and
deployed a rendering pipeline
on GCP.
Does everyone have microphones?
Or am I going to be
passing the microphone?
OK.
So Damien, do you want to start?
Just give a little bit of
an overview about Eight
VFX, some of the
work you've done,
and your decision to move
to Google Cloud Platform,
and how you've set that up?
DAMIEN BATAILLE: So
as you know, when
you are a company that with some
visual effect for commercial,
you have something to
render quickly, some image.
And because we have
a local render farm,
but we have to extend.
We have to have
more power to render
this image which
is why we choose
to render on the Google Cloud.
And what else?
TODD PRIVES: Great
start, absolutely.
Philippe, do you have
anything else to add to that?
PHILIPPE CHOTARD: Yes, so
excuse my English to begin with.
So we are a a very
small graphics studio.
We have about 20 artists.
So I know there is a list
with very big companies
here on the right.
And it looks like
Avere and Google Cloud
is made for big
companies, but it's not.
We have very specific needs.
When we need to
do some rendering,
we don't need
thousands of calls.
But we have local small
on-premise render farm.
So we sometime need to fire
up some up or on the Cloud.
So it's started for every
kind of company, the big one
and the small one, like us.
TODD PRIVES: Great,
so we have a few panel
questions I'd like to start
with and then certainly take
some questions from
the audience as well.
I think one of the things
I'd like to start with
is talking about latency.
Good question with
the Avere folks
and with the Eight VFX folks.
So how does Cloud impact
performance for you?
And how does that
affect your pipeline?
And how have you managed to
essentially push assets up
for optimal rendering?
DAMIEN BATAILLE: I know that
normally we can't-- for me,
the problem was that because we
are using a lot of custom data
inside a scene, like a lot
of texture and geometry,
the first solution that we try
is just to use some [INAUDIBLE]
up putting to scan all the scene
and from what we have to send
to the Cloud before it render.
And for me, it was
not a good solution
which is why I talk about
this with Philippe here
and I ask him if it is
possible to have something that
can transfer over in real time
between my company and Google
Cloud.
And Philippe told
me that there's
a solution which is Avere.
And I think he can
talk about this.
PHILIPPE CHOTARD: So
in my previous company,
we had physical Avere cluster.
It was composed of six nodes.
And we add about five
petabytes worth of data.
So this was how look at storage.
And before having Avere, we
really had a lot of IO issue.
And working with
Avere really help us.
So in this company, I wanted
to give a try to the cloud
solution because when we began
to do the testing of rendering
on the Cloud, we were
directly connecting our render
farm to our local
on-premise storage.
And it was awful.
So we began with Windows.
We are full Windows studio.
So our clients are
Windows machine.
Our storage is a
So yeah, basically
it's full Windows.
So when we began to do the
rendering on the Cloud,
we had some huge latency
issue that were not
only due to the number of
access done by the render,
but also because when
you use SMB from a one,
from a VPN connection, you will
have a very, very low transfer.
Because SMB is not
a protocol that
has been thought to
be used over one,
because it's a very
chatty protocol.
So we had to use NFS
between the cloud
and the on-premise storage.
So Avere was a good
solution for that,
because we would
put future nodes
on the cloud that would connect
to our on-premise storage
directly.
And using NFS, so we
wouldn't have any kind
of those latency issue.
And it will, of course,
help us because we
had a lot of virtual
render on the cloud that
will read the same files.
So basically, when you
were using the [INAUDIBLE]
caching system, you
read one file at once.
If you have like 100
nodes on the cloud,
and they access the same file
that we already redefined once.
So yeah, it was a huge benefit.
TODD PRIVES: So along those
lines, Jim, Avere as a filer.
When would you choose
or why should I choose
Avere over other filer options?
What's the ideal workflow
scenario for that?
JIM THOMPSON: Yeah,
anything that's cachable.
Again, Avere is a caching layer.
So if there's
something that-- and it
won't work for everything,
absolutely right.
You really have to
understand your flow and what
you're doing as far as
a render is concerned.
If there's going to be
repeatedly access content
and assets that you
need for the render,
the Avere layer,
caching layer is
going to be very important
to cache all that stuff.
Because otherwise, each
individual render node
is going to access the
storage, your on-prem storage,
over and over and over again.
So it's going to consume
all that throughput and all
that bandwidth that
you have from the cloud
back on to on-prem.
So having us in the picture
there, in the data stream,
is going to alleviate
all that latency.
I mean, not all of
it but most of it
from accessing all
that data that you're
on-prem and eventually
get your renders done
in a timely manner instead
of taking a much longer time.
TODD PRIVES: Thanks.
Jeff, next question for you.
Having worked with studios all
over the world now in terms
of getting them set up with
VFX rendering pipelines,
what do you see as these studios
finding the single biggest
challenge to getting
on to Cloud being?
JEFF KEMBER: I would
say the single biggest
challenge is the social
engineering with production.
The idea that well,
the artists are just
going to use all the disk
space and all the compute,
and pricing is going
to be a problem.
And how do we manage this.
I touched on it a
little bit earlier,
the idea of producing a
matrix, a spreadsheet of all
the various performance
aspects and also
trying to come up with a cost
for what render looks like.
But it really comes
down to, in my mind,
talking with
production and having
them manage how many machines
get spun up and such.
Or you add [INAUDIBLE] to it.
But no, there are--
the questions came up.
I was in a meeting yesterday
where it was like, well,
do we want the render
wranglers to do it?
Or do we want systems and
pipeline to manage it?
Well, no, it's always going
to be a production problem.
And that's kind of the
human factors issue.
The excellent work
that's been done
on security with Todd and
Matto and others, that's
like a solved problem
at this point.
And it's just sort
of propagating
throughout the industry.
There's obviously
additional work to be done,
but that isn't the
elephant in the room
to talk about when
we have file system
support and direct
connect and licensing
is a problem that is going away.
So really, it
just, for my money,
it comes down to
adoption in the workplace
and how to best engineer that.
TODD PRIVES: Back
to the Eight guys,
Jeff mentioned cost and
total cost of ownership.
So obviously you have a small
on-premise render farm now.
At what point do you decide
to put jobs on the Cloud?
And what sort of cost
analysis or comparisons
have you done to what it
costs to run a render locally
versus putting it on the cloud?
And what additional,
I guess benefits,
beyond just the
one to one dollars
do you see using
rendering on Cloud?
PHILIPPE CHOTARD: So on my
point of view as an IT guy,
I didn't really think about
it as a cost point of view.
But just the fact that when
you need to do something fast,
you have to have the
[INAUDIBLE] right now.
So if you want to see
it on the cost view,
usually when we
need to render stuff
that we need to
render fast, and we
don't have enough power on
site, we just rent machines.
Renting machine usually
you rent a machine
for one week, one month.
Using the Cloud, we just fire
up how many machine we want.
If we want five render,
we launch five render.
If we want 100 render, we
just we just launch them.
And it's for the
time we need them.
So if they render will take 12
hour, we will pay for 12 hour,
not for one week.
TODD PRIVES: And then
in terms of costing out
what it costs on Cloud, are you
able to bill these jobs back
to the clients?
Or do you figure it into the
actual cost of production?
Or how does that side of it fit
into your production schedules?
DAMIEN BATAILLE: Before
to start the project,
we try to know what will be the
costs of the rendering side.
And we try to add a maximum
of three render on the Cloud
which is why, before we
have a project, and we know,
so this is [INAUDIBLE]
inside the production.
TODD PRIVES: Jim, back
to you on the Avere side.
So we're starting to
see more and more small
studios that don't
necessarily have
an Avere on-premise
caching appliance deploying
Avere on the cloud.
Moonbot Studios in Louisiana
is a great example of that.
What information can
you give us about that?
And share the
advantages to studios
that might not
necessarily be investing
in an on-prem appliance,
but still getting
the benefits of being able
to set up a scalable Cloud
filer with cache.
JIM THOMPSON: Yeah, similar
to what Phillipe mentioned
here is that any time you need
some type of burst computing,
and this is what Moonbot needed.
They needed to get
some rendering done
in a timely manner.
In order to do that, it was just
physically impossible to get
stuff on-prem to do that.
They could afford
it, but the thing is
is that they just didn't
have enough space.
And there's other power
issues and other things.
And this is for it could
be anybody, absolutely,
across any type of environment.
So what they did is they had
to think about different ways
of doing this.
The only way to do that was
to actually put something up
in the Cloud and utilize the
cores to get the jobs done.
And the thing is, like
Philippe mentioned
as well, is that you
could spin up 100 cores,
you could spend up 2,000,
you could spin up 30,000,
depends on how quickly
you want the job done.
And that's what they did.
They actually spun up--
I can't remember exactly,
but I think it was
over 5,000 cores
at a time to render to
get their jobs done.
It's really that simple.
If you need something done
in a critical timeline,
you have to think
outside of the box
to actually find a solution.
And this is the
only way to do it.
TODD PRIVES: Great,
so back to you guys
on the whole job
management side of things,
since there is this concern
about costs on the Cloud,
how do you manage submissions?
Is it done through a
typical artist workflow?
Or is centralized to a render
wrangler or a different way
in your pipeline?
DAMIEN BATAILLE: Yeah, so
currently on the artist side,
this is just one check box.
You have to choose if you want
to render on the local render
farm or the Cloud render farm.
So we are using Deadline.
And the process is
exactly the same
between the Cloud and
the local render farm.
So on the pipeline
side, I didn't
have to do a lot of change.
So [INAUDIBLE] is
when user choose
to use a Cloud rendering,
we send the job
into the [INAUDIBLE] and
then we generate some--
we are using Avere,
so the render farm
will generate from
Maya or the VR scene.
And we always use the
local render farm.
And after another job, we take
all the VR scene and render
all of them inside the-- to the
Cloud from the cloud rendering.
TODD PRIVES: And Jeff,
what are your observations
working with the really
large studios that
are using 30,000 40,000
50,000 cores on GCP?
How do they manage artist
submission of jobs to Cloud?
JEFF KEMBER: Good question.
Yeah, we have some
companies that
are running more than
60,000 cores on a job.
You run into a scenario where
you have a ride film come in.
And it's 6 or 12k or 24k,
because it's a dome projection.
And you just don't have the
multi-hundred gig machines
in quantity with 64
cores sitting around.
So they're expensive.
But you can get them from us.
So in terms of
submitting jobs, some
of the companies
I'm working with
have their own queuing system.
There's two different
ways to do it.
One of them is to have
the queuing system
dynamically manage the
spin up of new machines.
Another way to do
is to actually use
a script to spin up
machines and then
add them to queuing system.
It offers a little more manual
control doing it that way.
And it just has to do
with whether you're
using a commercial or off the
shelf-- oh, sorry, a commercial
or roll your own queuing system.
So those are kind of the
distinctions in that regard.
It also comes back to the
production issue of who
gets to control that valve.
Most of the time it ends up
being someone in a CD sup
position who talks with
production and controls
how many machines
are brought online.
A couple customers
I work with that
were using a really
dynamic model where
they're averaging their usage.
So they've budgeted to
render like tens of thousands
of cores on a sustained level.
But they're able
to say, hey, I only
want to run-- like if I'm good
for 10,000 cores for 24 hours,
they'll run 20,000 cores for
12 and utilize the wall clock
savings.
So that's kind of more
advanced, but that's
really beneficial for
the artist as well.
TODD PRIVES: So I just
have one more question
before we open up
to the audience.
So having set up a cloud
rendering pipeline,
what recommendations
can you give
to those in the audience who
are looking to set something up
based on your experience so far?
DAMIEN BATAILLE: I
think for the pipeline,
before we have to have good IT.
And no, because for me, the
workflow render or the gerbil
is exactly the same between
the cloud rendering.
This is completely
transparent for me.
So I didn't have to do a lot
of change inside the pipeline,
because of cloud rendering,
we know what we are using,
what file we are to render.
This is more an IT work
than a pipeline work.
So it is why this is really
busy and to integrate
to sign the pipeline.
TODD PRIVES: Great, thanks.
Some questions
from the audience?
Someone out there has got to
be-- Yeah, go ahead to the mic.
AUDIENCE: My name is
[INAUDIBLE] from XVR.
Do you guys have any
solution for live broadcasts
in terms of pipeline, interest
points, as well as the caching,
let's say?
JEFF KEMBER: So in terms
of a real time transcode--
AUDIENCE: Yes
JEFF KEMBER: --and such?
Yeah, there are some
solutions for that.
We can talk in more
detail afterward.
But yeah, there's a
number of partners
we have that are able
to do a real time
transcode with a
variety of output files
with different codecs and
different resolutions and such.
So that definitely happens.
The majority of
customers I work with
are doing an offline transcode.
And that's super easy to do.
The real time, as
you know, latency
does play, and the question
of how many seconds
do you want between ingest
and push up to the CDN.
The other questions include,
are you pushing to your prem,
and then you're doing a
distribution from there
locally?
Or using Fastly or we have
a variety of partners.
We also have our
own CDN as well,
so happy to talk with
you more about that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JEFF KEMBER: Thanks.
TODD PRIVES: Any
other questions?
John.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF KEMBER: Sorry, just we
have people remote as well.
We're recording.
AUDIENCE: What ISBs are
you guys here with in LA,
and what bandwidth
are you working with?
And was that ever a
question or an issue?
JEFF KEMBER: Yeah, no,
we have really fat pipes
here in LA One
Wiltshire for sure,
and I can check the
network diagram to see.
We have multiple
peering locations, but--
AUDIENCE: From a
studio standpoint.
JEFF KEMBER: Well, from
a studio standpoint,
in terms of how large a
pipe can you get into us?
Or--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
is that a concern
at all when you're dealing with
the cloud rendering and stuff?
JEFF KEMBER: So- yeah, go.
PHILIPPE CHOTARD:
So we at Eight VFX,
we have a basic 100
megabit link that
can have sometimes
very bad latency.
So I've noticed that when
we have under 70 millisecond
latency, you will have great
transfer even using SMB.
And if you have over let's
say 100 millisecond latency,
you have to use NFS.
And we can-- when we
do some basic transfer
between on-premise and the
cloud, we can max out the link.
And so when we transfer
it, that with the cache
Avere we just use all
the available bandwidth.
We don't have--
now with Avere, we
don't have any real
bandwidth issue.
We did before because
all the renders would use
that single 100 megabyte link.
In the future, we would
like to use a better link.
Not more speed, because
100 megabits is enough.
But maybe with a lower latency.
JEFF KEMBER: We just
have, for the data point,
one customer in Central Asia was
doing a 60+ 1,000 core render.
They had a 250 megabits
symmetric pipe with Avere.
And they were rendering in Iowa,
so 140, 150 milliseconds away.
We also have customers with
dual bonded 10 gig pipes
into us as well.
So it runs the whole gamut.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Mark Lemons with Deluxe.
My question is as you've done
this, how much of your go
forward render node
provisioning is,
if you were planning
on future projects,
would be Cloud versus on-prem?
DAMIEN BATAILLE:
Oh, I think it's
different a lot about
the size of the project,
because we have a
local render farm.
We use like 14 [INAUDIBLE].
And for little
project, this is OK.
But when we know that
this is a big project,
and when we are
doing a bid, we know
that we have to get-- we have
to do a lot of rendering.
It is here that we
decide OK, for this shirt
or for this sequence, we
will use the Cloud rendering.
PHILIPPE CHOTARD: Until
now, until a few months ago,
we were using 100%
local rendering.
But now we know
that for the future,
we won't do as many render
nodes as we were planning to,
because we have this online
resource available all
the time.
So we will be moving
office in a few months.
And the rendering, the
sizing of the power
of all the racks for the
render is not as a big issue
as it was before
we use the Cloud.
DAMIEN BATAILLE: Yeah, he
give us a good security,
because before he was
a little bit scared
to get some big project because
we did not have any Cloud
renderings, so we
didn't know if you can
render all the project on it.
But now because we know that,
we have unlimited [INAUDIBLE]
we didn't have an
affinity to render.
TODD PRIVES: Great.
Question here.
AUDIENCE: Mike Shadow with
Deluxe Creative Services.
You have multiple locations
at Eight VFX I saw.
And do you share projects
across those locations
that have used the Cloud?
And are there issues that
you didn't anticipate?
PHILIPPE CHOTARD: Currently
we-- Cloud rendering
is working in New York.
So now, we have a location
in Los Angeles, in New York,
and in London.
Currently, the only location
that is using cloud rendering
is Los Angeles.
We share project between
New York and Los Angeles.
The pipes Damien wrote is able
to synchronize all the assets
between the facilities.
It's funny that you ask this
question because this morning,
our CEO ask us, can we do
cloud rendering in New York?
I said, yes because
it's exactly the same.
Basically, in Los Angeles
on the artist point of view,
you just click one
button to say, OK,
I want to render on the cloud.
Clicking this button will add
your job in a specific group.
So after that deadline, we
say, OK, this is render cloud.
I will first begin
to render locally.
If I don't have
enough power locally,
then I will fire certain
amounts up for cloud rendering.
So this is exactly the same
since halfpipe is the same
in Los Angeles and New York.
They can do the same.
They didn't do it yet,
but they can do it.
The only thing they
have to do before,
of course, obviously, is to set
up a VPN between the facility
to our cloud network.
And, yeah, it should be the
same, should be all the same.
DAMIEN BATAILLE:
Currently we are
using Aspera to synchronize all
the assets and all the pipeline
between New York
and Los Angeles.
TODD PRIVES: Any
other questions?
Chris.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Obviously you've started to
replace part of your render
farmer with Cloud, and it's
been a good solution for you,
and obviously a replacement
for the rental model
that you probably had before.
But do you see yourself
moving completely to Cloud?
And not only that but actually
replacing the workstations
with Cloud machines
down the line
where you can actually
just VPN or just
get into the machine remotely?
PHILIPPE CHOTARD: So for
the rendering point of view,
we still want to have
some local render power.
We don't want to put
everything on the cloud,
because our VFX studio, we do
rendering, at least some hours
of rendering every day.
So on the cost
point of view, it's
more interesting to have
at least a certain amount
of local rendering power and to
have the ability on the Cloud
to have more power,
availability.
So this is for the
rendering aspect.
After that-- so you asked
for the workstation, right?
We are currently testing some
solution with [INAUDIBLE]
maybe this technology
that's will--
it's a [INAUDIBLE] solution
that is quite cheap compared
to the [INAUDIBLE] solution.
And that will allow
you to connect
to not only physical
distant machine but also
virtual machines.
So until now, we've
done some testing
with not artist workstation
because of the GPU stuff.
But on the classical
station, producable station,
connected either to
physical workstation
or virtual workstation,
using VMware, it works.
And now with the new
version of VMware
that is ending that stuff,
they will enter the GPUs.
So we are really thinking
about in the future, immediate
future, to neutralize some
of the artist workstation
using PC over IP solutions.
So I didn't think
yet about if we
will do it on whole local data
center or on the Google Cloud.
But yeah, I will test
this very soon, I guess.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a
figure in your head on what's
the maximum latency that
will be acceptable for artist
workstation?
PHILIPPE CHOTARD: Yeah, so it's
about the same latency I talked
about before, 70 millisecond
is when your artists will begin
to bitch about the latency.
They won't notice before.
Actually last week,
I've put an artists
on the PC over IP set up
without telling him anything.
So there was a workstation right
near him that was shut off.
It was not running.
And yeah, it was working.
And he didn't know he
was not working locally
but on the virtual machine.
JEFF KEMBER: We have
run some tests-- well,
I shouldn't say we, but I
have customers who run in here
about some tests.
And they echo that as well.
It's typically the Mari artists
who are most temperamental.
Every brush stroke gets written,
so they want SSDs locally.
But lighters and everyone else
can certainly be pushed off.
The testing other customers
have done suggests a 20 to 40
millisecond.
But we've also had
numbers as high as 80
with artists who
were doing modeling
when you're pulling verts.
That and painting, those
are the two critical ones.
But we've had compers
running at 100 milliseconds
without a problem.
So I think there's some variance
within the job functions.
TODD PRIVES: Any
other questions?
OK, well, I'd like to--
JIM THOMPSON: Right,
so I know all you
guys are into the X Games.
So this is going
to go great when
you're doing your activities.
It's a GoPro.
Put on the end of your
surfboard, dirt bike, whatever.
So I'm going to
yell out a number,
and it means nothing to me.
Three.
Anthony, right on.
You got a GoPro.
TODD PRIVES:
Congratulations, Anthony.
I'd like to thank our
panelists, our presenters,
SADA Systems who's here in
the back, Simon and his team
if you have any questions
regarding system integration.
Thank you to all
of you for coming.
And thank you to Lauren for
putting this all together.
So we'll all be here if you
have questions afterwards.
[APPLAUSE]